just stand back arrow position I am
denied the somewhat important
Oh big dog the Julian week you spin a a
week marathon and now giant creature is
going into his nest
sit the final bit of him once that's in
we close up that hatch giant creature
goes into slumber tired sake but you
know when you see their reaction makes
it worthwhile
there were moments that were just pure
magic really it was like that's so cool
my favorite part was actually when I
could sneak outside and watch people
that was fine yeah this is the best
thing ever I come across I love to come
in for 20 years
stand back step on a ladder and watch
this thing walk across the sidewalk is
really cool rock fighter go gets up from
the car and as I'm walking
okay meaning better giant creature it
was a landmark for comic-con it was a
crazy set out to go bigger and more
innovative and more insane and we
accomplished I give you a fist bump
boom is my new best friend this is
the animal side my mouth
your baby smells delicious
by the Palestinian up not you
man way foot and gonna watch YouTube
channel for videos on making up
so now you're done you feeling like next
year the possibility for you yeah this
is never and never done this is invited
by this time Nick here we're going to
mount last year's on this year's and add
like another layer it's going to be a
whole nother thing it's going to be a
three-fer next year we're going to have
a fight or something it's going to be
crazy
check out the wired channel the scene
calm for the entire giant creatures
series